ونتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه الاغوار حيث قام قام فلسطينيون
بحسب الانباء الاوليه والموليه باطلاق
النار على سياره
فيها ثلاثه مستوطنات قتلتان منهما حتى
الان بحسب المعلومات الوارده واصيبت ثالثه
باصابات خطيره كما نشاهد مشاهدينا قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي في المنطقه والتي فرضت
طوقا امنيه على المكان ومازال رجال الشرطه
يفحصون ايضا ما يتوفر من ادله وهذا ايضا
يتزامن مع الجهود الذي التي يبذلها الجيش
الاسرائيلي
القبض او اعتقال منفذ هذه العمليه حيث قام
بفرض طوق امني وايضا اغلاق المنافذ في
اريحا ونابلس منعا لهروب المنفذ هذه
العمليه الى خارج هذه المنطقه
نذكر مشاهدينا ايضا بانه اكدت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان الجيش مازال يطارد
منفذ العمليه واكد ايضا رؤساء العربيه ان
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو يجري الان
مشاورات امنيه مع كبار المسؤولين بعد
اطلاق النار هذا في الاغوار وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه ايضا مشاهدينا افادت بان وزير
الدفاع يعقد اجتماعا مع كبار المسؤولين
لتقييم الوضع الامني ونذكر مشاهدينا مره
اخرى بان انه تم اغلاق مداخله ومخارج
اريحا ونابلس لمنع هروب منفذ اطلاق النار
في الاغوار هذه العمليه التي اسفلت حتى
الان عن مقتني
مستوطنتين واصابه ثالثه بجروح خطيره كما
افادت الانباء الوارده من هناك